Your next task is to update the sample
app to let users see the daily special.
But of course,
you'll need daily specials to suit
all kinds of food preferences.
Vegetarian, vegan, fish only and more.
And you want diners of all nationalities
to be able to read the daily special
in their own language.
How do you code your app to offer
the right daily special and
the right language for each person?
According to their food preferences.
>> Really?
You want me to code like that?
>> No, you don't have to write
conditional code for every possibility.
You can't, anyway because who knows
what your chef is going to dream up for
the daily special next month.
Let alone tomorrow.
The good news is that using TagManager
you only have to write the code once,
in a straightforward way and
then you can use TagManager
to set the special each day.
You can update the value in
the dashboard whenever your chef invents
a new, creative concoction to
offer to unsuspecting diners.
You won't need to update your app code
just because the chef switches to
a gingerbread garnish
instead of a honeycomb sauce.